stéphane leclerc je dirige la société
students nous sommes installés à skis
cube à la société a été créée en 2018
par trois associés nous sommes éditeurs
de logiciels mais nous proposons une
solution qu'une plateforme saas
accessible en ligne pour les prévisions
des ventes
[Musique]
notre solution permet à nos clients de
faire des prévisions automatiquement
mais surtout de les suivre au fait que
la précision de ses prévisions et leur
fiabilité pour identifier les produits
en fait qui sont critiques qui sont le
plus important pour l'activité de nos
clients est vraiment se focaliser
vraiment sur ces produits-là
automatiquement nous avons des clients
dans l'industrie manufacturière pour le
monde du commerce également dans le
médical et la santé est également dans
l'agroalimentaire nous avons des clients
notamment au mexique aux états-unis en
australie dans l'agro alimentaire
typiquement un client va vouloir faire
des prévisions à la semaine ou au mois
typiquement la semaine s'il va
gérer son site de production et pour
éviter d'avoir des pertes de matière
donc l'idée c'est de prendre les données
historiques de part de tous les articles
qui ont été vendues sur les trois
dernières années est l'outil
automatiquement va générer en fait pour
les douze prochaines semaines les
meilleures prévisions pour chaque
article
[Musique]
actuellement nous sommes en phase
d'amorçage nous sommes accompagnés par
wilko pour la partie développement
commercial puisqu'en fait il accompagne
les start up et accélère les startups
jusqu'aux premiers millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires wilko nous amène en
fait un mentorat donc typiquement nous
avons un mentor qui nous est dédié pour
nous accompagner sur la problématique
principale qui est celle de la
l'expansion commerciale également nous
pouvons participer à des ateliers qui
sont spécialisés comme je recommande
comment financer développer la société
pour cette expansion pour financer cette
expansion commerciale le programme
d'accompagnement de wilko en fait de
nous permettre d'atteindre 1 million
d'euros d'ici 2024 ou avant
[Musique]